HERE YOU SEE IT.
IN THE STATE OF MARYLAND, CNN
NOW PROJECTS THAT THE INCUMBENT
DUTCH RUPERSBURGER WILL BE
RE-ELECTED.
IMPORTANT WIN IN MARYLAND.
WE'RE MAKING ANOTHER ONE AS
WELL.
IN MICHIGAN, DAN KILDEE, THE
DEMOCRATIC REPRESENTATIVE WILL
BE RE-ELECTED.
WE ARE NOW READY TO PROJECT.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IS
REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT'S CLOSE.
>> LET'S COME BACK AGAIN.
THESE ARE RACES, FOLLOW ALONG,
IT'S IMPORTANT IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT YOU THINK REPUBLICANS HAVE
THE MAJORITY.
THESE ARE THE RACES WHERE
CANDIDATES ARE AHEAD.
THEY'RE NOT CALLED RACES SO
REPUBLICANS ARE ON A PATH AS WE
SPEAK NOW IF THINGS DON'T CHANGE
TO PERHAPS HAVE A NARROW
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
CALLED RACES, 218 YOU NEED TO
CONTROL THE HOUSE.
202-186.
YOU GAVE TWO MORE -- THEY ARE
HOLDS.
>> TWO MORE DEMOCRATS.
>> SO YOU LOOK AT THE MAP RIGHT
NOW.
THEN YOU COME TO WHAT RACES HAVE
WE NOT CALLED?
WE HAVE 47 RACES STILL TO CALL,
RIGHT?
19 OF THOSE, YOU KNOW,
COMPETITIVE SEAT, REPUBLICANS
ARE LEADING, 18 THE DEMOCRATS
ARE LEADING SO YOU HAVE A
TUG-OF-WAR GOING ON RIGHT NOW,
AGAIN, IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE WE
ARE AHEAD, AHEAD, LOGIC TELLS
YOU LOOKING AT THAT MAP THAT
THERE IS STILL A MATHEMATICAL
POSSIBILITY THAT DEMOCRATS HOLD
THEIR MAJORITY.
THE PROBABILITY IS THAT
REPUBLICANS GET A NARROW
MAJORITY AS YOU COUNT THEM
THROUGH.
BUT WE'VE GOT A WAYS TO GO AND
ONE THING YOU'RE SEEING IN THE
MAP, NUMBER ONE, THIS TALK OF A
BIG RED WAVE SIMPLY DID NOT
HAPPEN.
>> NO SHELLACKING.
>> IF THERE IS A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IT COMPLICATES JOE
BIDEN'S LIFE BUT DEMOCRATS WILL
DEFY THE AVERAGES IN THE HOUSE
ALEX PEREZ AS WE GO THROUGH, THE
QUESTION IS HOW BIG AND, AGAIN,
THERE IS A MATHEMATICAL
POSSIBILITY THE DEMOCRATS HOLE
THE HOUSE.
WE'LL KEEP COUNTING AS WE GO.
THAT NUMBER TELLS YOU THE
PROBABILITY IS YOU HAVE A NARROW
HOUSE MAJORITY THAT EVERY TIME
YOU PROJECT A RACE AND A
DEMOCRAT BOTH HOLDS FOR THE
DEMOCRAT, THAT'S 9 CHALLENGE --
JUST LIKE IN SENATE RACES WE
NEED PATIENCE AND GO THROUGH THE
COUNT TODAY.
WE'LL KNOW A LOT MORE AT THE END
OF THE DAY BUT SOME OF THESE OUT
HERE, THEY COULD TAKE DAYS AND
DAYS TO COUNT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A WHILE.
IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS LIKE KEVIN McCARTHY
YOU'RE PRETTY NERVOUS RIGHT NOW
ABOUT THIS POTENTIAL REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
>> HE ONCE TALKED ABOUT 60 SEATS
THEN 30 SEATS, THE MATH SAYS
IT'S GOING TO BE BELOW THAT,
ALL RIGHT, IN THE STATE OF
ARIZONA, CNN IS NOW PROJECTING
THAT ELI CRANE, THE REPUBLICAN,
WILL BE ELECTED TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ARIZONA.
THIS IS ARIZONA'S DISTRICT
NUMBER 2.
ELI CRANE LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOING
TO BE THE NEXT REPRESENTATIVE
FROM ARIZONA RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S ONE PROJECTION.
WE HAVE ANOTHER FROM
PENNSYLVANIA RIGHT NOW AS WELL.
LET'S GET THAT UP ON THE SCREEN
IF WE CAN.
YEAH, THERE YOU SEE IT.
SUSAN WILDE, THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT, SHE IS GOING TO BE
RE-ELECTED.
WE CAN NOW PROJECT EVEN THOUGH
IT SAYS TOO EARLY TO CALL WE'RE
PROJECTING SHE WILL BE THE
WINNER DEFEATING LISA SCHELLER.
SO WE GOT TWO MORE PROJECTIONS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
SET THE SCENE FOR US.
>> SET THIS DOWN RIGHT HERE.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
I SPENT TIME IN SUSAN WILD'S
DISTRICT EARLIER IN THE CAMPAIGN
TALKING ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT THIS
WAS TO HER IN THE SENSE OF
TRYING TO WIN.
THIS IS AHEAD AS YOU COME
THROUGH THE DISTRICTS AND COME
UP HERE.
THIS IS HER DISTRICT,
PENNSYLVANIA 7th DISTRICT.
LOOK HOW CLOSE THIS WAS, HER
VIEW WHEN I VISITED, WOLF, WAS
IF SHE HELD ON SHE BELIEVED IF
SHE HELD ON AND IF MATT
CARTWRIGHT HELD ON AS YOU SEE
HE'S LEADING RIGHT THERE RIGHT
NOW THAT THIS WOULD PROTECT THE
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY.
THAT MAY BE OVERLY OPTIMISTIC
BUT THE FACT SHE HELD ON TELLS
YOU IF THERE IS A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY AND WE'RE NOT THERE YET
IT WILL BE A NARROW ONE, MUCH
MORE NARROW THAN REPUBLICANS
EXPECTED IN THE 7th AND 8th
DISTRICTS, REMATCHES AND
REPUBLICANS THOUGHT BECAUSE OF
THAT IN A BETTER CLIMATE THEY
WOULD WIN THEM.
DEMOCRATS ARELESS LEADING IN THE
COMPETITIVE RACES IN THE WESTERN
PART OF THE STATE AND COME BACK
TO WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW, THAT
ARIZONA RACE YOU JUST CALLED,
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT THE
REPUBLICANS PICK UP ONE IN
ARIZONA, THE DEMOCRAT TOM O
O'HALLERAN LOSING.
WHERE ARE WE?
THIS IS NOT A FINAL NUMBER.
THIS IS LEADING SO REPUBLICANS
NEED 218 TO GET THE MAJORITY.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WERE ON A
PLOTTING PATH TO GET THERE, BUT
THEY'RE NOT THERE YET.
IT IS STILL IF YOU COME TO
CALLED RACES, 203-187.
MATHEMATICALLY POSSIBLE AS YOU
LOOK AT THE UNCALLED RACE, IT IS
MATHEMATICALLY POSSIBLE THE
DEMOCRATS HOLD THEIR MAJORITY.
THE MORE LIKELY SCENARIO LOOK AT
WHERE THEY ARE, IS THAT
REPUBLICANS GET TO A MAJORITY
BUT LET'S GET THROUGH THE DAY IS
WHAT THIS TELLS YOU LEADING IN
ENOUGH RACES BUT WE'VE BEEN
FULLY SURPRISED AS OF YESTERDAY,
SURPRISES TODAY.
LET'S CONTINUE THE COUNT.
IF THE REPUBLICANS DO KEEP THAT
AND WIN THE MAJORITY THOUGH IT'S
GOING TO BE A NARROW ONE, NOT
WHAT REPUBLICANS EXPECTED EVEN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ESPECIALLY
BACK A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO,
NOW, THE POINT YOU JUST MADE
ABOUT THE SENATE IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL SO LET'S SWITCH THE MAP
AND LOOK HERE, NUMBER ONE, NOW,
RAPHAEL WARNOCK, THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT CONTINUES TO LEAD IN
GEORGIA.
BUT THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOW
PROJECTING A RUNOFF MEANS
DECEMBER 6th WE WILL HAVE
ANOTHER RUNOFF ELECTION IN
GEORGIA.
IT WAS THE RUNOFF ELECTION IN
JANUARY 2021, JON OSSOFF,
RAPHAEL WARNOCK WON.
THAT'S WHY THEY CONTROL THE
SENATE.
THAT COULD COME DOWN TO BE THE
CASE AGAIN, LET ME SWITCH MAPS.
THIS GETS FASCINATING AS WE
COUNT THE REST, TWO LEFT, RIGHT?
WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHO WILL BE
LEADING HERE BUT LEAVE THAT ONE
HERE.
WE'LL KEEP THAT OFF THE BOARD.
WHERE ARE WE RIGHT NOW?
LET ME COME BACK TO WHERE WE
ARE.
50/50 SENATE.
RIGHT.
NOW WE COME BACK TO OUR
PROJECTIONS HERE, RIGHT?
SO WHAT DO WE HAVE?
DEMOCRATS WON THIS, FETTERMAN
WON SO THAT GETS THEM TO 49.
THIS ONE WE'LL LEAVE.
THESE ARE ALL SETTLED.
WHAT'S LEFT?
THESE TWO RACES OUT HERE, RIGHT
NOW THE DEMOCRAT IS LEADING,
LEADING IN ARIZONA, STILL A
SIZABLE CHUNK OF VOTES TO BE
COUNTED IN MARICOPA COUNTY AND
PIMA COUNTY AND ELSEWHERE IN
ARIZONA.
FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT LET'S
SAY KELLY HOLDS ON THEN WE COME
DOWN HERE, LOOK AT THIS MAP.
49/49.
RIGHT NOW THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE ADAM LAXALT IS LEADING
IN NEVADA.
STILL A LOT OF VOTES TO BE
COUNTED SO WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
THIS RACE NOW BECOMES CRITICAL
ESPECIALLY IF KELLY HOLES WHICH
IS A MORE SIZABLE LEAD.
IN LAXALT WINS AND KELLY HOLDS
ON, GEORGIA WILL ONCE AGAIN
DETERMINE IN A RUNOFF THE BAT
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
IF CORTEZ MASTO CAN COME BACK AS
THEY COUNT THE REMAINING BALLOTS
IN CLARK COUNTY, IF SHE CAN COME
BACK AND KELLY HOLDS ON THE
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE A MAJORITY
AND THIS WILL BE AT 51, BECAUSE
OF 50/50 IF REPUBLICANS WIN THIS
THE VICE PRESIDENT STILL WINS
THE TIE SO NOW THAT WE PROJECT
THISES IS A RUNOFF A LOT OF
FOCUS OUT HERE IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS AS THEY CONTINUE TO
COUNT THOSE VOTES.
THIS SEAT HERE BECOMES
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THE
REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO HAVE
THAT SEAT ESPECIALLY IF MARK
KELLY HOLDS ON TO THAT LEAD.
IF REPUBLICANS LOSE THE LEAD IN
NEVADA AND KELLY HOLDS ON THERE
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE MAJORITY.
>> WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS IN
NEVADA RIGHT NOW FOR LAXALT
AND --
>> LET'S SWITCH MAPS TO GET OUR
LIVE VOTE FEED.
YOU COME UP THE MAP.
IT'S FASCINATINGLY CLOSE RIGHT
NOW BUT THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT NUMBER.
YOU SEE 50, IF YOU ROUND THAT UP
TO 47 BUT THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT NUMBER RIGHT THERE,
80% ESTIMATED --
>> 20% --
>> 20% REPORTING AND A LOT OF IT
IS RIGHT HERE, 74% OF THE
POPULATION IN NEVADA LIVES IN
VEGAS AND THE SPRAWLING SUBURBS,
FAST-GROWING SUBURBS AROUND IT.
INCREDIBLE COMPETITION HERE.
AT THE MOMENT THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT TO WATCH.
AS THIS NUMBER CLIMBS, DOES HER
NUMBER CLIMB?
JOE BIDEN WON CLARK COUNTY BY
NINE POINTS.
I GOT THE CUFF LINK TOO CLOSE TO
THE END THERE BUT IF YOU COME
DOWN HERE BACK TO CLARK COUNTY
JOE BIDEN WINS THIS BY NINE
POINTS, MASTO WINNING BY A
LITTLE MORE THAN LESS, LESS THAN
FIVE, ABSOLUTELY SIGNIFICANT.
AS THE OTHER BALLOTS COME IN
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING IT'S A LOT
OF MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
THEY THINK THEY WILL SPREAD THIS
AND THAT BECOMES KEY IN THE GAME
OF SENATE CHESS, IT'S NOT A GAME
BUT IN THE ART OF SENATE CHESS
THOSE TWO WESTERN SEATS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
UNDERSTANDING WILL GEORGIA BE
FOR THE MAJORITY AGAIN OR WILL
THE DEMOCRATS PROTECT THEIR
MAJORITY OUT HERE AND GEORGIA
WILL BE CAN THEY GET TO 51?
MATH TO DO TODAY.
>> HOUSE AND SENATE, THE
MAJORITY STILL VERY MUCH UP IN
THE AIR AT THIS MOMENT.